when faced with a foe of overwhelming
power we alone might not be able to do
anything at all in some circumstances
but it's especially at times like these
that we can count on our friends that's
to say our nakama hello and welcome to
vinnie tube today we're discussing a
list of what we consider are some of the
top team fights in anime this is mostly
at crucial moments of the story or when
the characters themselves understand and
form teams according to their unique
circumstances if anything this is where
things start to become exciting for us
the viewers as we see some of our
favorite characters fight together or
even face off against each other
[Music]
[Music]
we start off the list with everyone
versus hendrickson from the anime the
seven deadly sins
this was the first season finale battle
of this action fantasy anime it was
quite exciting to watch as each of the
sins comes into the battle against
hendrickson who becomes quite
overpowered after he absorbs the power
of the grey demon of course esquena
isn't present at this time otherwise the
battle might have lost some of its shine
together they surprise hendrickson by
combining their attacks through the
revenge counter skill which meliodas can
perform it's a great finish to the story
at this point and it set the
expectations quite high for what was to
come in the future for the show
at number nine on our list it's chrono's
fight against the zeno and silva zoldak
from hunter hunter
the zoldiac assassins have been called
in to handle the issue of the phantom
troop going wild in the streets of york
new city after locating him in the
basement of a building zeno and silva
confront crollo they're aware of crolo's
gift of stealing other abilities and
zeno proves his worth as a tactful
fighter as he realizes crollo has to
meet some conditions to actually
activate this ability what follows is an
intense fight where zeno and silva pair
off against crollo not giving him enough
leverage to meet the conditions to steal
an ability finally zeno pins down crollo
and urges silva to shoot them both
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
next on our list is the straw hats
facing off against oars in thriller bark
this is a crazy situation that follows
luffy's shadow getting implanted into a
huge giant known as oars the whole crew
have to get together to help defeat the
huge monster they all struggle as always
doesn't take any damage at all it's at
this point chopper informs the crew to
break the spine of the giant stopping
ores from being able to stand up it's
exciting to see the whole crew come
together and display their various
skills and functions as a group they
come together quite nicely and show off
their best skills
auntie huncle
moving on to number seven we have
atsushi and akutagawa versus francis
from bungo stray dogs
francis has a unique ability that lets
him increase his physical strength by
spending his assets and with the wealth
he possesses he truly is overpowered at
this point atsushi in his manned tiger
hybrid mode as well as akutagama in his
demonic armor form both push themselves
to their limits to protect a city and
people they've come to love and care for
it's an intense fight as both keep
taking hits from francis at full power
but still endure the assault to
counter-attack it's only when they work
together that their son was successful
it's a great fight to watch because of
atsushi and akutagawa's teamwork
considering their relationship
girl
[Music]
number six on our list is a scene from
dragon ball super yes it's where goku
android 17 and frieza together face off
against jiren
this fight happens towards the end of
the universal survival arc when
everyone's exhausted including jiren
who's remarkably still going strong
after facing goku in his perfected ultra
instinct form what makes this unique is
an odd series of events where goku teams
up with frieza and android 17. the three
form a battle plan against jiren with
the two sworn enemies fighting together
and trusting each other all of them
unleashed their full fury on jiren which
is easily one of the most iconic moments
of the series who would have thought
we'd actually see goku and frieza team
up one day huh
[Music]
sorry
[Music]
number four on our list is from the show
fate stay night unlimited blade works
it's the fight where rin shiro and saber
face off against caster and kazuki
this was an interesting fight because it
was initially thought of as an easy win
for the team of three which included an
exceptionally strong saber and a
talented as well as resourceful mage
like rin however in a surprising manner
kazuki proved himself to be quite the
exception among the masters and servants
taking on saber as well as taking down
rin after in this crucial moment shiro
overcomes his limits and shows his true
magical skill he remembers archer's
weapons and using projection magic
creates a copy of his swords with this
he's able to stand his ground against
kazuki which completely surprises rin
and castor this also gives saber enough
time to launch a surprise attack against
kazuki which he's able to evade thanks
to castor
[Music]
[Music]
next on our list at number three is from
guintama it's the scene where literally
everyone fights utsuro
utsuro has only one goal in mind and
that's to destroy everything to make
sure nothing exists and thereby ensuring
his death as well he's shown to be
extremely powerful enough to do this as
well when he single-handedly faces off
against all the various forces numerous
times
faced with this time crunch the entire
crew battle on against this insane
immortal it's an epic sequence where
everyone even shin patchy comes in to
try to fight utsuro it's really well
handled and quite satisfying to watch
moments like these make you realize this
show doesn't just focus on comic
elements and absurdist humor
[Music]
at number two we have the final battle
between father and everyone else
in this momentous conclusion of the
anime we watch as the elric brothers and
almost everyone they've ever been
involved with fighting out against the
almost godlike entity known as father
it's a nerve wrecking last few moments
that lead to a lot of new revelations
and truths it's quite exciting to watch
how all the emotion leading up to the
final episodes came to this epic finale
of a fight and almost everyone who's
helped or been helped by the elric
brothers shows up to play a part in his
high stake outworldly battle it's
definitely well worth the hype and is a
satisfying conclusion to a much
cherished series
um
and finally the number one fight in this
list is naruto and sasuke versus
momoshiki from boruto next generation
this sequence was talked about or at
least was doing the rounds on social
media for a long while when the episode
aired one of the major draws of the
fight was that favorites naruto and
sasuke teamed up together and go all out
to try to defeat another entity that's
somehow able to take on all their
ninjutsu admittedly it's a passionate
seed especially with the events leading
up to what they've become however what
truly took the breath away of the fans
or most of the anime viewers was the
fluid animation and the stunning visual
sequence that was used to show this epic
fight with a great mixture of ninjutsu
and taijitsu combined with some
beautiful animation this fight was
easily one of the best fights the series
ever had overall this is an amazing
fight sequence with the two main
characters coming together to fight and
to save the day against a foe that's
quite powerful to say the least
so did you enjoy our list then if so
please subscribe to the channel and hit
that like button don't forget to comment
with your favorite anime team fight in
the comments section below too thank you
and please do stay tuned for more great
content i'll see you next time on vini
tube
[Music]